the latest in school segregation was how
the headline of a recent new york times
op-ed described
private pandemic pods in which parents
get together and hire an in-person
teacher
while public schools remain remote the
pandemic pod says the writer will
exacerbate inequities racial segregation
and the opportunity gap
within schools business insider had a
slightly different take they said the
pods were inequitable
and inevitable and that the arrangements
were a dream come true for the school
choice movement
but are pandemic pods just the latest
tool through which white parents use
their financial and political clout to
separate out their children
thus increasing segregation and is the
solution to increase government spending
in k-12 schools so that all parents will
want to keep their kids in the public
system
that was the subject of an online soho
forum debate held on wednesday
september 16 2020. arguing for more
government spending was john hale
a professor of education at the
university of illinois at
urbana-champaign
arguing in favor of pods and other
parental innovations was corey deangelis
the director of school choice at the
reason foundation
which publishes reason tv here's john
hale and corey deangelis
in an online debate moderated by the
soho forum's director
gene epstein
[Music]
well again tonight's resolution reads to
combat
inequality greater investments must be
made in public schools so as not to
accommodate
the formation of pandemic pods by
affluent parents
defending the resolution university of
illinois education professor
john hale opposing the resolution
reason foundation senior fellow corey
deangelis
i'll be keeping track of time and we'll
briefly interrupt each debater
to say when he has five minutes left and
one minute left
john you're first up to defend
the resolution good evening everybody my
name is uh john hale
from the university of illinois and it
is an absolute uh it's a pleasure to be
here thank you for the invitation
i really appreciate the opportunity to
participate in such
uh an important debate and question
right now
in um really in american history and
um while i'm associate professor of
education educational history at the
university of illinois
you know i come here tonight really as a
public education advocate
a father of two little girls and a very
concerned resident
of these united states and tonight i am
here to again argue
in favor of the resolution which reads
to combat inequality
greater investments must be made in
public schools so as
not to accommodate the formation of
pandemic
pods by affluent parents just to be
clear pandemic pods are small groups of
students in the k-12
school system who gather together for
in-person
instruction outside of the traditional
schooling system of course to
um keep safe during this pandemic that
that's raging around this
um they're also controversial because
pods can be pricey
complicated to organize they're
self-selecting and they're likely to be
popular among
families of privilege and affluence but
to really unpack the resolution and why
we should be in favor of it we are
looking at
i'm looking at this as a pandemic but
also a dual pandemic and here i am
looking at american educational research
association's use of the term dual
pandemic and also looking at
the american psychological association
as uh
racism as a pandemic so really what
we're getting here is to look at
how we confront a dual pandemic of both
covid
and essentially racism and
let me be very clear first of all is
when i look at
race and racial analysis parents should
not be
denied the right to form pandemic pods
um they have every right to form
pandemic pods and to choose
to form pandemic pods nor should parents
be
told to go back to school if they do not
want to physically send their children
to school this is something i understand
personally
that's not the debate the point here is
that
the focus should be on the fact that
policymakers must invest
and strategically govern schools to
avoid accommodating
and please we hear privileging
the formation of pods by affluent
parents at the expense
of those who cannot afford such luxuries
at this moment in time public schools
must receive the support to operate not
only as an effective solution to this
dual pandemic
but a safe and decent option
for the 51 million children that choose
to attend
a public school so
to unpack this larger debate i'm gonna
be focusing on four main talking points
first of which is that pandemic pods are
grounded in a racist history and we must
look at racism and understand how this
is impacting
pandemic lives second we're looking at
parity and
the uh and equal opportunities
that do not exist parody does not exist
equal opportunities do not exist that
are necessary to make a good choice
that the other side will be advocating
for ultimately
and um what little agency existed prior
to the pandemic have been
ravaged by this dual pandemic that faces
us today
third money does in fact matter
and because of that greater investment
is needed
and to this point i'll also say it's not
just financial investment it can also be
non-financial investment as well which
i'll elaborate later
and finally making greater investments
in education restores his perennial
vision that education
should be a common good
um and also that shares goals of
equality pandemic pods
ultimately move us away from the shared
value system
so to look at my first point pandemic
pods are grounded in a racist history
and we have to consider
the underlying racist principles
that foreign pandemic has so
to be up front of course there are black
and latinx
and indigenous uh lead pods today
clariton bird green mirror debs jp
gerald jennifer berkshire and others
have noted that current
pods however are compromised by largely
uh white and or economical economically
affluent
families it's been noted in the new york
times in washington post and others that
upwards of 75
of white people report that when they're
making these decisions
that the network of people that they
consult with to form
pods ultimately um they're only
discussing this matters with
other white people so in other words
with this largely
entirely white uh social network
and with no presence of black families
or families of color
we can map this out to a racial inequity
that underpins the formation of pandemic
cries today
and if we look at the broader definition
of school choice and to use uh dr dan
d'angelo's term of what school choices
anything alternative
to um a public uh school
right and pandemic pods fall into that
but other forms of choice
also reflect this racialized sort of
context
60 of all homeschooling students for
instance are white
60 of private school student population
are
white yet white students make up less
than 50 percent of the
traditional public school population so
it is clearly evident that pads are
racialized and merely perpetuate
a larger racist history therefore to
quote
uh clariton mcgreen that it is not a
leap
to predict that learning pods will
mirror the deeply
racially segregated lives of most
americans and this
of course builds on a much longer
history
i mean we can go back to south carolina
in 1740 virginia 1819
other southern uh states that their
first educational policy was in fact to
prohibit and forbid enslaved individuals
and enslaved communities
the right to read and write
to deny enslave communities a right to
an education
even in the north if historians have
documented
uh while some opportunity may have been
provided to
black families and other families of
color it was still largely segregated
so just if you look at the brown v board
of education decision
when in 1954 when the supreme court
determined that
such racial segregation was
unconstitutional
right we see white people pulling
out of this system okay so here we have
the sociological phenomenon of course of
white flight where white families are
leaving the city and urban centers in
mass to move to the suburbs and then
essentially
set up public schools in the suburbs
which are largely segregated just
due to residential patterns we have
segregation academies which are formed
by southern legislatures
with oftentimes with public money
schools private schools that are
exclusively white as to avoid
desegregated
public schools we have freedom of choice
plans in which white people argue that
there is a constitutional right to
freedom of association which is true but
they apply that right to
not have to be forced by government
government schools
to go to um a desegregated
public school this of course is the
historic basis for school choice that we
know today
it's also the basis for this phenomenon
we see
recently of school districts
actually succeeding pulling out of
public school districts
um infamous cases in shelby county in
tennessee
around the city of memphis okay and also
as nicole hannah jones documents very
thoroughly in the state of alabama
so while people are pulling out again
and by its very nature it's
largely a white-led movement we must
consider race in the institutional
racism that's
underpinning pandemic powers this does
not mean
of course pandemic pod parents if you
will
are racist all it means is that we have
to look at the larger systemic nature
of racism in public education something
which this forum actually debated a few
weeks ago about the police
you know system being racist and the
soho forum agreed to it so i mean it's
not too much of a jump to see that the
school system is racist as well
or i'm rather it's underpinned by racist
policy my second point
uh is interrelated
parody does not exist and equal
opportunities do not exist
for parents who need to make the best
choices
because they don't exist in order to
make
the choice to go to the best schools
available to
them not only that what little agency
existed before the pandemic
right has been devastated by this dual
pandemic of
coronavirus and racism which has exposed
tragic truths
cdc reported and you can just look at
how this pandemic has played itself out
and this is
of course captured um uh the new cycles
of as this pandemic unfolds
uh cdc has reported that over 21 percent
of covet cases in the united states were
african-americans and nearly 34 percent
were
latinx despite the fact that these
groups comprise only 13 and 18
of the u.s population respectively um
in cases where you know for instance
school choice
research says uh will indicate that
cities like milwaukee are doing a really
good job in school choice we actually
see
african-american population in these
cities where they suffer
nearly four times and let next family
suffer six
times that the amount of whites in terms
of who ends up in a hospital
who comes down with the coronavirus so
it's exposing these tragic racial truths
it also in terms of the economy we see
that 48
of all adults living in households where
at least one pers
one person lose employment income since
mid-march is
or the onset of what we now know is of
course the coronal virus
for black and hispanic uh in latinx
households rather
this rises to 53 and 62
respectively we also see that nearly 33
of all adults live in households where
they expect someone
to lose employment yet with black and
latinx families this rises to nearly 50
percent
additionally we see that when we work
quarantine
and sheltering in place or rather
supposed to we see that in the largest
cities in the united states
black and latinx families
comprise as much as 75 percent of
all the city's essential workers so
essentially we have a racialized
essential working population that has to
go back to work thus expose them to the
virus
let's look at how this plays out within
schools nearly 17
million children it is reported lack
access to
high-speed internet connection and it's
also been found that one in three black
latinx and american indian households
lack such internet access
making children in these homes much more
likely than their white peers to be
disconnected from online
learning the format that we've come to
depend on during this
pandemic additionally
social capital is required to understand
this convoluted choice process
um such as you know educational savings
accounts
which requires um an understanding of a
process it requires a financial
investment it requires social networks
with the knowledge to complete the
process
to know how to apply and where it
requires time taken out during working
hours to decipher this convoluted
process
and it also includes a demand for
resources including transportation and
proximity
proximity to the very best schools
available to us today
so what we need what we see then with
this pen
this dual pandemic essentially is that
the ability for people to make a choice
to even
get to the point to make a good choice
greater investment is needed this leads
to my
the third point that money matters and
greater investment is of course
needed to deny investment in public
education
starts to border on an extreme position
to ignore the fact that pods and the
best choice options
do not require investment once given the
choice is a gross oversight
moreover it is disingenuous to cut
funding while acknowledging that more
money is needed
for instance let's just look at the cost
of pandemic pods to begin with
at least reports are coming in that you
need at least thirty dollars an hour to
hire a tutor
or a hundred dollars or more to hire a
more qualified tutor
not to mention professionally trained
licensed teachers
have cost upwards of a hundred thousand
dollars per year for pandemic
pods to hire and work with such teachers
this clearly surpasses an
800 to 1200 a month expenditure for
these small pods which is
what a lot of people are paying for
rents and mortgages
so there is an increase expectation that
people have to buy into this
uh in order to pay for these pandemic
products
and then of course right money of course
matters it costs money to
to organize a pandemic bud and
economists across the board
curable jackson bruce baker david martin
david martinez and others have cited
dozens of studies have shown that money
matters
uh studies across the board show that
there's a 10
increase in per pupil spending for each
year for all 12 years of public schools
leads to um
more completed years in college just
under one half seven percent higher
wages and 3.2
percentage point reduction in the annual
incidence of adult
poverty uh caribou jackson for instance
also finds that a thousand dollar
reduction
in per pupil spending due to the
recession which even happened before the
pandemic of course
leads to a decline in student test
scores of about 3.9 percent of a
standard deviation
money matters even eric
hannisch someone oftentimes uh cited by
the
other side has recently come out to say
that
we are uninvesting under investing in
education in the united states and this
is a very serious issue
he recognized finally to the fourth
point
making greater investments actually
restores a historic vision that
education should be
a common good sometimes you know
disputed about maybe it's perhaps a
public
but let's draw on the historic language
of a common good with goals of equality
and opportunity historically national
leaders since thomas jefferson ben
franklin
benjamin rush noah webster have
published
thoughts and philosophies and ideas of
their
particular educational philosophies that
education
must be inextricably linked to the
survival of the republic
and the democracy it has been understood
since the founding of our nation that
education should be a common
uh good to this extent that states have
picked up upon the sentiment and
enshrine this in state constitutions
just read for instance arkansas is a is
a good example
where it reads quote intelligence and
virtue being the safeguards liberty and
the bulwark of a free and good in
government
this state shall ever maintain a general
suitable and efficient system of
republic schools california a general
diffusion of knowledge and intelligence
being essential
to the preservation of rights uh and
liberties of all people this legislator
shall provide a system of free
public schools this goes on and on to
the extent
where it is understood that schools
should and must be part of this
common good of a shared value system and
we have believed this historically to
the extent
that schools cannot be simplified as a
place to simply
study a curriculum and to take a test
school serve a
much larger social function schools are
the main source of child care
for working parents and where it is
seeing this during the pending
schools are a key place for children to
get healthy meals
schools are crucial for the health of
okay thank you for the health of all
children schools are especially
important for dealing with the mental
health of young people
schools essentially serve as oasis for
children who are suffering from
traumatic instances outside of the
school it is a
state haven and a necessary space for
tens of millions of children in short
publication
public education has been seen as a
common good and we must continue to
invest in this when we're trying to
survive
this dual pandemic greater investment is
needed it's not asking a whole lot it's
just to invest in a system
where tens of millions of children must
go either in an online format or in
person
to otherwise borders upon in a uh
opposite uh an extreme position that
dismisses
both the history of our very system of
public education
and it ignores the existing problems
that we must
address as a nation during this dual pin
perfect uh just three seconds under john
um so
uh you did well uh thanks a lot
uh now uh corey uh dangerous is up
for the negative right take it away
corey
all right cool yeah thank you so much
everybody for coming out i want to thank
john hale for going over his arguments
for his proposal to throw more money at
the problem
i'm going to argue against that proposal
and offer a counter proposal that i
think
beats his proposal every step of the way
and
basic logic would have it if you prefer
my proposal to john hale's proposal
that would have you reject uh john
hill's proposal to
throw more money at the public school
system
my proposal is to fund students directly
instead of institutions
and allow students to take their
education dollars to whatever
educational setting works best for them
and that still could be the traditional
public school system if that works
for a particular family and if the
traditional public school system
is high quality for for their family and
if uh
the school has a great reopening plan
that works for them families should
absolutely be able to continue choosing
that but if for whatever reason that
does not work
the money should follow the child the
money that already exists in the
education system for that child should
follow them to wherever they're getting
an education that can be in a private
school to pay for tuition and fees
and that could be in a pandemic pod
which is the main point of this
discussion today and i will say this
should lead to more equality
because advantage folks are already
going around and forming pandemic pods
advantage folks can already afford to
pay for private school out of pocket
my proposal leads to more equality of
opportunity by allowing for less
advantaged families
to have the means to be able to pay for
these alternatives as well
and this is similar to how we fund so
many other taxpayer-funded initiatives
from pell grants to
pre-k programs to food stamps with all
these other initiatives the funding
rightly goes to the families and then
the families have a choice of where to
spend that money
with food stamps you can choose the
money goes to the family and the family
can choose to spend the money at walmart
whole foods trader joe's
we should do the same thing when it
comes to k-12 education
so i think we should fund the student
instead of the system we should fund the
student instead of the institution
just like we do with all these other
programs and
after all the money is supposed to be
meant for educating the child it's not
supposed to be meant for propping up and
protecting a government-run monopoly
everybody in here would think it would
be absolutely ridiculous if you're if we
forced
low-income families to take their food
stamps to a residentially assigned
government-run grocery store
it's absolutely ridiculous similarly in
the k-12 education to not allow families
to have the choice to take their
children's education dollars
to wherever they're getting a proper
education uh so that's
my main main proposal and i would also
argue that it should be tied to a
percentage of what is already spent in
the traditional public school system
we already spend around fifteen thousand
dollars per child per year in the
traditional public school system and
that amount has increased by 280 percent
in real terms since 1960
it's nearly doubled since 1980 and it's
increased by around 40
in inflation adjusted terms since 1990.
i think it should be about 80 of the
money that already exists in the system
this could create a taxpayer savings it
doesn't have to be that way
but this is one way to ensure that
there's either fiscal neutrality or a
taxpayer savings with my proposal
john hale's proposal i would imagine
would take a lot of money he didn't
really give us a number as to how much
money is enough
when it gets to greater investments i
guess we'll get into that in the next
five minute segment but i didn't hear
any amounts of how much this is going to
take for
more equality in the traditional public
school system but my incentive has a lot
of benefits along with it
we don't have to guess about how much
the money is going to cost i already
told you it's going to be 80
or higher or some number around there of
the 15 000 that we already spend
some states spend less some states spend
more so it would be
relative to what your child would have
gotten in the traditional public school
system
hale's proposal assumes that incentives
do not matter
so you can throw more and more money
into a system and it could matter it and
it could matter for student outcomes in
certain
locations but it's it's not going to
matter if there are no
incentives to spend that money wisely on
the individual student
and i would argue the traditional public
school system has a lot of monopoly
power
in that individual families in the
current system are residentially
assigned to a particular school
uh just based on where they live and so
that provides a lot of monopoly power in
addition to
compulsory funding through property
taxes and so
since they know they have your money
regardless and and since the
transaction costs are high for switching
to another school
there's a lot of monopoly power in the
residentially assigned traditional
public
school system just imagine if you're
residentially assigned to your nearest
grocery store they wouldn't really have
a strong incentive to do a good job
because they know that they would have
you
on the hook as a customer and i think
this whole debate about the school
reopenings has more
to do with incentives and i will say my
proposal does allow for bottom-up
incentives and accountability to be
introduced into the system
by allowing individual families not just
rich families less advantaged families
as well
to vote with their feet to the provider
of the educational service that works
best for them
and that could lead to improvements in
the traditional public schools as well
and we have 28 studies on this topic
what happens in response to private
school choice competition in the
traditional public schools for the
children who
remain in those schools for whatever
reason 26 of the 28 studies find
statistically significant positive
competitive effects
on the children who remain in the
traditional public school system so this
could be a tide
that lifts all boats and just think
about uh
the reopening plans of different
businesses today private businesses
including private schools and day cares
are fighting to reopen but public
schools all too often are fighting to
remain closed
and i think the difference here is one
of incentives one of these sectors
gets your money regardless of how well
their reopening decision works for their
customers
and if you look at the education week
database on this covering over 900
school districts in the united states
which covers around
forty percent of all students in the
traditional public school system
uh around three quarters of the hundred
largest school districts in that data
set are not reopening with any in-person
instruction available to any students
at all and if we would expect that more
money would lead to
better reopening plans or better
educational outcomes we would think that
our nape scores would
would have gone up over time but we
essentially see a huge increases in
spending over time but then
uh pretty flat uh standardized test
score outcomes when it comes to the make
long-term trend uh data on this
but then also uh we should also expect
that in the education week data set that
we would see that districts that spend
more money should be more likely to
reopen in person if it's all about
the financial uh uh if it's all about
the
the finances and the system but if you
pull up the education week data and do a
simple correlation between spending per
pupil
in the school district and whether they
reopened in person or not it's actually
a negative correlation you would expect
it to be a positive correlation
if more money led to being more able to
reopen in person and this relationship
this negative relationship which is
pretty shocking
stays stays uh significant and negative
even after controlling for a whole bunch
of different demographic characteristics
such as the racial competition
composition in the area the age
distribution in the area and even median
household income in the area
i think it has more to do with politics
and power dynamics than it does
with the amount of money that's in the
system i mean just think about dc public
schools in my area
they spend over thirty one thousand
dollars per child per year yet they're
not reopening for
any in-person instruction until at least
november 6th
um and so they spend way more than the
national average uh a little over
twice the national average and they're
not they're not reopening in person but
then you have florida that spends much
less than the national average and 73
of the school districts in florida are
reopening with some with full-time
in-person instruction available to all
students
despite not having a ton of resources at
a per on a per people basis
then you look at states like california
that have stronger teachers unions and
spend more than florida
and they only about four percent of the
school districts in the education week
database reported that they're going to
reopen full-time uh with in-person
instruction for all students
so california stronger teachers unions
and spends more yet they're less likely
to reopen and then if you look in dc
i already told you how much the public
schools spend the charter schools spend
less than the the traditional public
schools in dc they actually spend about
29 percent less
on a per people basis in the nutritional
public schools in dc yet the charter
schools are sending me things in the
mail about uh
hybrid options available to students and
also full-time virtual learning if
parents want that
as well so they're more likely to give
families options but you would expect if
the money
was the big deal about the reopening
then the charter schools should be less
likely to reopen in person but they're
actually
more likely to reopen in person and i
think that has to do with two things
charter schools are a lot less likely to
be unionized in the traditional public
schools
and charter schools have a more
competitive incentive
to get it right because they know they
need to advertise to the parents in
order to
give them something that the individual
families want and a lot of families do
want some type of in-person instruction
for
their families but they are still
offering the full-time
uh virtual school option as well in the
charter schools in dc
so i don't think it's a big money issue
and
although john didn't tell us how much
money he's going he would like to pour
into the system there are some
unintended impacts of increasing taxes
to pay for this um and i would expect it
would be a lot of money but
we'll get into that in a little bit but
if you increase the property taxes that
could increase the price
of renting that unit unit and that could
hurt disadvantaged communities by
increasing their rent prices
through indirectly through raising
property taxes that could also if it's
funded through sales tax that could hurt
uh disadvantaged communities by not
allowing them to
to consume at the same rate and it could
also shutter their employment
opportunities and then that could lead
to
unemployment for disadvantaged
communities as well so
and then i'm not sure if the schools are
going to reopen if
even if there are greater investments in
the school system
and so with john hale's proposal we have
to do a lot of assumptions about
the schools making the right decision
and and actually reopening and i'm not
sure if they'll actually do that
they may spend the money on other things
just look at the cares act funding we've
already allocated over 13 billion
dollars
to k-12 education from the federal
government yet the schools aren't
reopened that's about
a quarter of what the federal government
spends in total on k-12
education each year so we've already
poured a lot of money into the school
system and they're not reopening
um but also the schools may yeah they
may get more money and then just say
oh we reassessed the situation we
actually
asked for a hundred billion but you know
what we think we need 150 billion and i
think that has to do with incentives
they have a pretty strong incentive to
remain closed just imagine if walmart
got your grocery money each week and you
had to continue paying them
regardless of their decision to reopen
they would have a much
different incentive than what they do
have today
my proposal beats hale's proposal in a
couple of other ways as well
my proposal gets into
so you don't have to assume goodwill on
the for on the side of the traditional
public schools because even if the
traditional public schools don't make a
good reopening decision
or they don't invest the money wisely
and do a good job then the families
would still
be able to uh opt out but if the schools
do make a good decision
then the families would still be able to
pick their traditional public schools so
we don't have to make an assumption
about what the schools are going to do
with the money because
if they don't make the right decision
people could vote with their fee and
take their money elsewhere
i mean if a walmart doesn't reopen you
can take your food stamps elsewhere you
can take
your money elsewhere if the school
doesn't reopen each family should be
able to take their child's education
dollars elsewhere at the same time
my proposal allows for individual needs
to be met
hale's proposal is a one-size-fits-all
solution that might not work it for
everybody
a school reopening plan may work for a
lot of uh individual families but
perhaps you're from a a family where
you're living with your grandparents and
the student
um has a high risk condition for the
virus
maybe that school reopening plan still
doesn't work for them in the public
school system
so maybe it would still be beneficial
for them to be able to use that money to
go to a pandemic pod
and so that allows for this uh
recognition of individual needs that
aren't the same as the
needs of perhaps the majority and even
with uh even if you have access to a
quote-unquote high-quality public school
it might not be a good match for every
individual child
they may not be interested in they may
be getting bullied in that public school
system
and i still think they should be able to
have a choice as well because look again
rich people yep rich people already have
school choice they can already afford to
pay
for a property that's residentially
assigned to the best traditional public
schools in the current system
rich people can already afford to pay
for private school out of pocket rich
people can already afford the
to have the option of the pandemic pods
all i'm saying is that we should allow
other people to have that option as well
even if hale's proposal is correct in
that
putting more money into the public
school system incentivizes families to
go back into the traditional public
school system
those advantaged families will still
have the power to make the
choice to exit that system so they would
still have that choice so it doesn't
really lead to equality of
opportunity which funding the students
directly would give more families that
ability to
make that choice even if it's the public
school system they should still be able
to make that choice
my proposal is safer in theory if you
believe in social distancing
my proposal allows families to exit the
public school system and spread out to
other locations with smaller class sizes
and private schools but then also
pandemic pods which are smaller
locations
and that'll decrease the class sizes in
the traditional public schools as well
hale's proposal is instead trying to
incentivize people to stay in the
traditional public school system
which um would could lead to less social
distancing and less safety
and again this also assumes that the
families are choosing the pandemic pods
only because of safety
and it could be that the the traditional
public schools spend the money on things
that do make the schools a little bit
safer
but for the individual families they may
say that well this isn't safe enough
i would still like the pandemic pod
because this is kind of a big factory
warehouse setting you i know you have
all the
uh equipment and materials so the family
still may
not go back into the traditional public
school system and even if they did go
back into the traditional public school
system the traditional public school
system is inherently
uh unequal that you have certain
families that are residentially assigned
to higher quality
traditional public schools then you have
others that are not assigned to to the
high quality schools and they're stuck
in the
failing traditional public schools so
even if hale gets this proposal correct
it would incentivize families to go back
into their original schools
and i don't see how that could lead to
more equality mine doesn't
eradicate inequality entirely but it
does lead to more incentives for
bottom-up accountability for the lower
quality schools to improve
and it does give disadvantaged families
options right now and that's another
point is that
hale's proposal could take a long time
look we've already been waiting a long
time for the schools to reopen and
high-income families affluent families
have already been
accessing alternatives to the system for
the past few months i don't think
low-income families should have to wait
any longer they should be able to access
these alternatives
like the affluent families right now the
best way to do that in a quick manner
is to allow the funding to follow the
child to wherever they're getting an
education
uh and so with hale's proposal to you
know kind of
invest in the traditional public school
system a lot of the issues about the
safely reopening schools have to do with
the buildings themselves
and the the the you know like the the
height
high class sizes and the big uh
structure of the school buildings
themselves and so
re shaping the buildings could take a
long time which
uh low income families shouldn't have to
wait any longer
advantaged families haven't had to wait
at all and with school choice
the disadvantaged families wouldn't have
had to wait for the past couple of
months either
and then also we don't know how much
money this is going to take with my
proposal we know how much money it's
going to take
health's proposal will be an increase in
expense mine will be a
theoretically it could be a decrease in
taxpayer expense but it also
could be a budget neutral
proposal as well so in summary it's just
to hit it really quickly
my proposal beats hales and that it's uh
costs less doesn't cost more and doesn't
come along with all the unintended
consequences of raising
uh rent on people raising uh sales tax
for people or
putting people out of business by
increasing corporate income taxes or
however it's going to be funded
my proposal allows for considers the
needs of individual families which could
differ from the one size
fits all approach in the traditional
public school system
and each child is unique and so they
should be able to sort based on those
unique interests and needs
that they have and their individual
family circumstances
hail's proposal doesn't introduce any
new competitive incentives for the
public school system to spend that money
wisely so we have to do a lot of
assuming about how the schools are going
to spend the money
with my proposal it allows for
additional competitive pressures for the
public schools to get better and then
for
students to be able to access schools
that are better for them
also the hail's proposal does not expand
opportunity for disadvantaged
communities they still just have to wait
on the government
to uh improve their education system
they've low-income families have been
waiting decades already for the
government to pour more money into the
public school system to improve and they
haven't seen those improvements they
shouldn't have to wait anymore they
should get the money right now and it
should follow their child
to a better educational option and i can
get into this a little
later i know i'm a little over but uh my
proposal
uh well it could lead to more safety by
spreading children out in more locations
could lead to more equality of
opportunity and it could benefit
teachers too we already have evidence of
teachers
exiting the public school system for
pandemic pods thanks
that was five seconds over for corey so
uh
we won't find you too bad too badly for
that but i had a technical difficulties
i'm just kidding
no no no actually no actually cory you
considered it i know
yeah you know i'm very flexible give you
the ten seconds but uh
you guys are doing well in terms of time
both of you and no problem at all
uh and now we go into the rebuttal
portion that's five minutes apiece
uh so uh uh john uh you get
your chance of rebuttal take it away
john
okay you know cory there's a lot said
i'm going to try to respond what i can
try to to break it down to um i think
the most essential points
and part of that i'm going to say just
requires about what my
um it's not a proposal as much as the
defense of
black families latinx families and
families of color in public schools that
investment is needed so
and in terms of i feel a little pressure
to put a number on that but let me
explain where i'm coming from with
greater investments and i'm coming
at this from a historical point of view
and a social uh political point of view
as well
is that investment can mean more money
it can be more money um in many ways it
should be because i've been
and worked and organized around many of
these schools where you do need more
money but
that later but it can also mean you know
if you look at when the first pandemic
pods
uh news hit the summer like jp gerald
and mira debs
said one way to invest is if not
necessarily spend more money
it's showing up to pressure the public
schools to do the right thing
that's an investment if you're forming a
pandemic pod
and you are worrying about paying the
best teacher you can
and staying safe right you're pulling
out of that system you're pulling out of
the public discourse
to to pressure unions to do the right
thing and to pressure your local school
the right thing so
investment also includes that and also
in terms of i'm not going to put an
exact number on it because if
our as you know corey right or and
and hopefully people on that is i assume
we all do how
incredibly complicated our funding
structure is in the united states
local state federal and even i i spent
seven years uh teaching in charleston
south carolina it's a hundred mile long
school district and you know
you could break down numbers about
person expenditures even within this
district
and it looks quite different i mean
schools that were
purportedly failing at students received
more than the best performing public
schools in the area so something there's
intra-district disparity
that these sort of broad numbers just
don't cover but let me get back to this
point of investment
what i'm proposing if you will but what
i'm really defending and asking you to
consider
what no matter how you vote on it
tonight whatever
it's to just take the idea that
investment means
believing in and empowering and
uplifting those who have been
historically
disenfranchised by a racist public
school system
cory you mentioned like for decades
people have been asking and waiting for
the government to do something
they've been people have been waiting
families of color black families
in particular coming from the south for
the past 10 years
are not waiting they're already
demanding change and people
aren't listening an investment could be
simply listening to what people want in
their schools
i trust parents in public schools i
trust parents who choose public schools
they know more than i do sit in here
coming from afar in champaign illinois
telling them what
what they need to do no they knew they
knew they know best
it's it's a problem that extends itself
to the civil rights movement
here we're looking at none other than
september clark ella baker bob moses
dave dennis i can go on and on and on
that solutions are held in the community
i want to empower
those communities and i'm going to
listen to them as they tell me
what investment they need because that
is the solution
and just something else i think for the
remainder of the minutes i'm
you know personally and i know a lot
i've heard a lot of
people coming forward with articles what
what not i'm very
highly uncomfortable with this idea
about
comparing schools which my daughters are
going to go to
to a walmart to compare it they're going
to school
like it's using a food stamp that you
know
schools as i mentioned in my opening and
i'll say it again because i think it was
um perhaps missed or just you know
there's a lot happening right
um especially with faulty zoom wires
that schools are much
more than a place just to learn a
curriculum that just to go and listen to
a teacher and take a test right that's
one way to look at what
schools provide health uh
health and well-being for our students
stu schools can and should be a safe
place for students coming from
traumatic backgrounds or experienced
trauma in the pandemic the dual pandemic
has exacerbated this right schools are
not only a safe place but they are a
meeting place for people to try to
improve our democracy
so to try to put one single number on
that and try to say like this is like a
walmart
i i don't want to go send my daughters
to a school that's like black friday and
people are like
mobbing each other to get the best
product i don't i don't want a teacher
who's paid as much as a greeter and i
love the greeters at walmart don't get
me wrong
but they're underpaid and they're
honestly are not insured properly i
don't want to send my school
my kids to a walmart and even i've heard
before like a trader joe's or something
okay well then it's a grocery that's in
a gentrified white area and you're
limiting the choice so
i think that you know a better analogy
than food stamps and walmart
that's not the school that i'm talking
about that's not the school that
historically we're talking about
and quite frankly in this pandemic we're
talking about
safe spaces for our students oh yeah
yeah okay you just went uh
nine seconds over so we're all fine uh
but uh
thanks uh thank you john and um
then uh hold on a second i've gotta
clear this
and um so corey you've got uh five
minute rebuttal uh take it away corey
cool thank you so much uh john uh
for going over the rebuttal points i i
i would still like to know how much more
investment is needed in the traditional
public school system
and i know it's really difficult to come
pin down a number but this is the
argument that's made over and over again
over the past few decades is we need a
little bit more money
we'll do better this time we promise we
need a little bit more money and we've
increased every single decade
on the us on the national average per
pupil expenditures after adjusting for
inflation
since 1960 it's increased by 280 percent
so i really would like a number i'm i'm
giving people a number i'm saying it's
80
of what they would have gotten in the
traditional public school system and
that's another benefit of
my proposal that it's there's more
certainty you don't have to do all this
guesswork and it's not something that
we've tried
a million uh times before uh and i
wanted to clarify really quickly with
the walmart analogy i'm not saying
schools or walmarts that's why i also
try to
put in the analogy of pre-k programs and
pell grants which
those are educational institutions where
the money goes to the family and the
family has a choice in the matter
and a lot of the people who do not like
uh
k-12 having the funding followed the
child uh
will support pre-k uh funding following
the child and
pell grant funding for the child which
the only reason i can
kind of conjure up as to why you would
be for one and not the other is there's
an in
entrenched special interests in
protecting the status quo when it comes
to k-12 education whereas in pre-k
and pel and higher ed the uh the default
is more choice and more freedom already
and we already have systems where people
can take their money to
uh particular institutions um i just
want to get
uh re respond to a couple of points john
hill pointed out that 50
51 million students choose to attend
public schools the united states they
don't make that choice
they make that choice because it's uh
that's the only choice that they have
and they don't they can't afford
to pay twice to pay for a private school
out of pocket while paying for the
traditional public school
um through the property tax system if
people had the choice
many more would choose private schools
and pandemic pod options
and i think john hill understands this
because he said this in his
recent podcasts where he believes that
allowing the money to follow the child
would be a quote devastating blow to the
public school system
why would it be a devastating blow to
the public school system it's it's an
admission that when people are given the
option
there won't be 90 of kids in traditional
public schools they'll go somewhere else
because they
like the alternative options even when
they're given less money than what is
spent on them in the traditional public
school system
uh i also want to point out uh john hill
spent a lot of his time talking about
racist
origins of school choice or the apparent
racist origins of school choice
i would argue that school choice uh
uh was around long before the 1950s we'd
have we've had three private school
voucher programs in the united states
that started
in the late 1800s in maine vermont
and new hampshire and those didn't have
racist origins and i also will say in
the 1950s people
oppose school choice segregationists
actually propos
oppose school choice because they knew
it would allow other students into their
schools
and it would allow for more racial
integration and in fact
if you look at the evidence on the
private school choice literature there's
only eight or nine studies on this
all but one of those studies find that
on net school
private school choice programs today
lead to racial integration because it
allows for
students to escape racially segregated
schools and we cannot forget that the
traditional public school system
is a segregated system john hill also
pointed out that
uh and conceded that's the traditional
public school system there
are aspects of systemic racism in it and
that's
a good argument for school choice why
force people into a system
that suffers from systemic racism why
not allow people to vote with their feet
uh and to go to an alternative uh
situation
john hale also pointed out that i'm glad
he pointed out that there's
a lot of success with school choice in
milwaukee and i just want to thank him
for
making my argument for me there have
been two random assignment studies in
milwaukee both have found some
suggestive evidence of winning a lottery
to attend a private school in milwaukee
would increase standardized test scores
but we've seen other matching studies
find in
increases in college enrollment and high
school graduation rates and then also
one of my studies i've done with patrick
wolf
has found a reduction in criminal
activity in two different peer-reviewed
studies
in milwaukee so thanks so much for you
know checking that out i also want to
point out
so listeners uh something that i thought
was disturbing
john hill pointed out that some families
may
not have the social networks and
knowledge to do the process
but a lot of processes take a lot of
information to gather but you know i
don't have to be
a medical doctor to choose my doctor i
don't have to and with food stamps that
it takes a lot it's very difficult to
find the right foods for your family
should we take away food stamps from
disadvantaged families just because it
takes some information gathering no we
should still give them that power to
make that choice
um even if it's a difficult decision for
them to make and i think all families
have the best
incentives and information about what
their own children need more so than a
bureaucrat sitting in an office
that's like hundreds of miles away as it
goes over and also all right that's fine
okay thank you for that uh rebuttal
and now we go to uh the
q and a portion of
the evening and uh
the loose rules are that either of you
have the prerogative to ask the other
question at any time
let's begin by asking john at this point
you can
uh reserve the right to do so later at
this point is there a
question that you would like to put to
cory or do you want to wait
on and wait for audience questions or
whatever but do you want to exercise
that right at this point
yeah can i just clarify or ask a
clarifying point about
um milwaukee and why that works and i
still haven't really received a direct
response to about the pandemic of racism
i mean i'm about low income which seems
to be you know
loosely you know correlated you're using
as a way to talk about race so just
clarify about
milwaukee specifically and why it's
working just maybe just something to
talk about
and then also how when we talk about
um i'll start with that one question
mark and then connecting
to that how does following the money
or if i'm putting money so that money
follows a student right so empower
students through this
sort of um you know
a handout if you will or check right
you're giving students
a voucher to go over to to use the
schools right
so how does that still meet the historic
and social function of schools that have
been established since
ultimately in the 18th century yeah i
want to point out that
if you ask minority families if they
like school choice they're much more
likely to support school choice than
white families
so i think uh you know when you ask them
you know what what what
minority families want we should allow
them to make a choice
in the matter and so yeah it's not just
low-income families who
want school choice it's all sorts of
families who want school choice
and in milwaukee it's not the only place
that has found positive effects of
school choice programs we have charter
schools all across the nation
in most states about 45 different states
have charter schools
with voucher programs there are 17
experimental studies of the effects of
private school voucher programs on test
scores
and the majority of those have found
statistically significant positive
effects
on for overall or for some subgroups of
students
and only one of those experimental two
of those experimental evaluations of the
17 have found statistically significant
negative effects so it's
it's hard to tell exactly what's causing
the difference in outcomes because even
if you have a gold standard evaluation
it's something called a black box
intervention where you know that
you know winning the lottery is what
caused the better outcomes we don't know
the exact mechanisms
of what's going on a lot of people have
theorized about
what could cause the difference in
outcomes one of the best main theories
is that
it's competitive pressures and i will
say there are the 28 other studies that
i studied at the beginning of this 26 of
28 have found positive competitive
effects on the traditional public
schools so the traditional public
schools
respond pretty positively for the most
part if you look at the evidence on that
as well
and just because something has existed
for a long time doesn't mean that that's
the best system for
each individual family now and i'm not
calling to eliminate the public school
system i think i think that should still
be part of the choice set
people should still be able to choose i
i made sure i started with that people
should still be able to choose the
public school
if that works for them but if it doesn't
they should be able to select some other
option uh that is more able to cater to
their individual needs
so john you'll put a pretty fine point
on the answer john was pressing
for an explanation about why milwaukee
other places have a greater success
you mentioned competitive pressures
could you elaborate on that for
in terms of john's question for the
moment yeah the private schools
uh have a strong incentive to cater to
their needs of their customers because
they know that those families can take
their money elsewhere
so because private schools have a strong
incentive to cater to the needs of those
families
that could lead to better outcomes uh
through the voucher program because
they're
able to access schools that already have
those incentives
to to do a better job all right and then
uh bull's in your court do you want at
this point to exercise the option of
putting a question to john
what do you want to wave that um yeah so
i i guess uh one of my main questions
for john is uh based on what i pointed
out about that uh podcast where he said
that he believed that
if we had a situation like esa's or
having the money follow the child
he believes that it would be a quote
devastating blow to the public system
why would giving families a choice be a
devastating blow to the system that
they're residentially assigned to
um so you know focusing on greater
investments which is the resolution
before so that great investments need to
be made and this is a
comment that i'll put into context
because you asked specifically but to
make greater investments we have to
understand
that privileging
and accommodating choice at this point
in this historic moment in the united
states
can have a devastating impact let's just
look at educational savings cones for
instance so when we
when i hear other sides talk about
educational savings accounts
and it we just in a lot of economists
right seem to assume
that this is already an equal playing
field
right however why is it then if it is an
equal playing field right
why do we have so many black and latinx
and indigenous american families without
a savings account in the banks
whatsoever
so we assume that giving families and
students more choice we're assuming
there's an equal playing around but it's
not
right we can't make that assumption so
if we all of a sudden say okay we're
going to move to educational savings
account
and if i'm not mistaken you actually
called educational savings account a
panacea
at one point or alluded to the fact that
it can it can
raise all boats that in fact if you
actually look at what's going to happen
if you went to
educational savings going immediately
there's no parity and opportunity to
even
put it into savings accounts right
in some studies less than 70 to 75
percent of black atlantic families even
have
a savings account as they exist by some
studies
and when you look at the historic
distrust of black and latinx families in
banks that that doesn't seem to be a
fair option to just look at one example
of
choice so that can have a devastating
impact
if you all of a sudden start to create
these savings accounts
and in arizona we we've seen money being
transferred from public schools to these
cities
it really doesn't work in terms of
providing quote unquote more
choice also historically i i gotta
correct that
that's just simply you know school
choice didn't exist from the beginning
of the founding of public education in
in in the united states school choice
specifically is has been traced
with consensus among historians to
milton friedman in 1955.
now robert gross is talking about but
school choice how we use it today
how we use it today is largely credited
with school choice
so providing that choice always has this
problematic relationship to
racism and when we propose choice as a
solution
we're not taking into account the uneven
playing field that already exists
that is why greater investment is needed
to even make that choice
to even to allow people to sort of
empower their individual lives
right to empower to make decision to be
empowered to invest in such savings
accounts
right that is why choice can have a very
negative effect
on um on families of color today
all right and john uh john i believe
that you had
a second question you wanted to put to
corey having to do with race
yeah so okay and then also when you so
milwaukee is very interested in from the
great state of wisconsin out in the
country but you know milwaukee
more power to milwaukee we seem to miss
when we're talking about milwaukee what
the historic origins of the vulture
and choice program there howard fuller
who i've interviewed extensively
and then you know basing a chapter in
him in my forthcoming
book check it out maybe gino sent the
amazon link out later
but um this actually grows out of the
civil rights movement
as a way to um
provide community control to the black
community in the city of milwaukee
derrick bell
founder of critical race theory came to
milwaukee to argue that perhaps this
public system isn't working
we need to have a community controlled
system and that's what they propose
choice in vouchers are sort of a
negotiated compromise after that and
howard fuller
has been critiqued heavily for that
he's oftentimes associated as one of the
strongest but very few black voices
in in terms and in favor of school
choice i don't think that's right
but what i'm saying is you know we need
to
see how choice evolved in milwaukee to
understand what the
what the issue is going on in milwaukee
also in the city of milwaukee
we have the pen the dual pandemic that
ravages that city
four times as many african-american
families in the city of milwaukee
six times the latinx families in the
city of milwaukee
come are are stricken with
the corona virus right so it still begs
the question
why are we going to disinvest for a
voucher system
that affects so few people at a national
scale to point to cities like milwaukee
in cleveland i saw come on
as a national solution it just to me
doesn't make sense and i just got to say
a little bit what we're talking about
with the solutions that need to happen
to point to milwaukee that's a majority
minority city where the majority of that
city or in the school system at least or
like chicago
and you point to you hand pick a few
studies and say this is what's
what's going on it's a little bit like
white people i'm sorry pointing to a
black friend and saying look i have a
black friend
i'm not racist right it's pointing to
these individual studies that say look
this is actually benefiting people
and it's not there is systemic racism
that needs to be addressed
okay that okay then that was the
statement and i guess
the question is uh could you respond to
that those objections about milwaukee
uh please answer the question corey yeah
i also just want to point out really
quickly that
voucher programs did exist in new
hampshire maine and vermont anybody
could look it up on google right now and
i'll send it in the comments in a second
they've existed since the 1800s in the
late 1800s the us
and either either way i mean in the
1950s there were people
that were segregationists that opposed
school choice and there were
segregationists that
approved of school choice there were
differences but then also this is a
genetic foul so you can't base the
uh the benefits of a policy today and
the motives of a policy today based on
uh how some people felt about the policy
a long time ago
and i wonder if john hale is against the
minimum wage uh because
the minimum wage has racist origins too
uh
would you i guess you can odd or not or
are are you um against the minimum wage
could you guys ask the question
milwaukee uh
please yeah so i didn't cherry-pick
studies i did go over some studies in
milwaukee but i excited the
preponderance of the evidence in
milwaukee
if you want to if you want me to cite
more i can go through all the studies in
milwaukee and there are five competitive
effects studies from milwaukee all
finding statistically significant
positive effects in the traditional
public schools
but i also cited all 17 experimental
studies i didn't just cite milwaukee
and i went through all those and i also
just want to point out for the listeners
really quickly
that each experimental study isn't
really a fair experiment because
the voucher programs are funded much
less than the traditional public schools
so when you find a null effect no
effects on test force for example
that implies a positive return on
investment because the the voucher
schools are using
lower funding amounts from the state
than the traditional public schools
all right at this point at this point
i should probably pay some attention
to a lot of audience questions that are
coming in
uh john and uh and corey you'll have the
opportunity to ask
each other questions a bit later uh
one question for you uh corey has been
that in your initial statement you were
constantly using
reopenings as a criteria
for uh the effectiveness of the public
schools versus
the private school this seemed to be a
doubt on the part of some questions as
to whether
reopenings are a useful criterion
could you address that objection yeah
the reason i was pointing out so much
about
the reopening debate today is because
it's it's relevant today but then also
the start of the pandemic pods at least
in in current memory is that a lot of
families were are seeking out pandemic
pods
because the schools aren't reopening for
in-person instruction
and um i would expect that one of
hale's arguments is that if you have
greater investment whether that's
through money or otherwise in the
traditional public school system
some of the families that exited the
system because of the schools not
reopening would come back into the
schools
and that's how you would uh have more uh
you know kind of equality under his um
proposal and so that's why i addressed
uh these score openings with in great
detail but we could also talk about
um kind of just investments in schools
over time
and and academic outcomes too if we want
to talk about those but
okay uh john uh do you want to uh
comment on
corey's response you want to go on to
another question
uh up to you john i mean there's a lot
of fascinating questions coming in
but um you know there's a lot to say i i
just want to say when we look
at sort of like investment at a time and
then we're going back to this argument
time and time again that you know that
this isn't taken away
from um public school investment i just
when we look at the cares that
specifically that one of the biggest
problems we had
are senators proposing legislation and
southern governors such as um governor
mcmaster
in the in the state of south carolina
where they're actually using that cares
act money
to fund private school vouchers to fund
private school options so it's a very
actually real threat during this
pandemic
that money is being proposed by
our current administration and current
senators
who want and and not to mention southern
governors like mcmaster
who are using that money supposed to
address that just the singular pandemic
of coronavirus and i put it into the
private school fund so i mean
i think it's a little bit again
disingenuous to say that
well you know people public education
advocates are you know are
making a false claim that we're taking
money away
but during this pandemic alone in the
past two months we have seen
southern legislators and the senators
who support them who also support
going back to school and playing
football in sec stands with 100 000
people there
who are just defying the laws of science
and medicine
are also proposing that you're using
federal
money and guess where that comes from of
course to go to
to privilege white affluent families
so i just want to re-emphasize that it
is a it's not a perceived threat it is a
threat and we've seen it during the
pandemic that people are actually
proposing
using this money for private options
when as
corey you know we can agree on nces
statistics at least
50 million kids are in the public
schools that's money you're taking
literally or proposed to take away even
though supreme court is shut down
the idea is out there okay
i think that uh john i think that you
addressed a somewhat different question
which is fine uh so uh yeah i think you
understand the question then uh that
john just addressed cory having to do
with the recent allocation of the cares
act
so could you address that question yeah
if you look at uh oklahoma
is one of the states i think he that
john is referring to only
about five percent of the total cares
act funding went to students directly
through private school vouchers
and in oklahoma they gave preference to
low-income families so it's not
disproportionately going to privileged
families i think more than five percent
of the funding should have went directly
to families the funding is supposed to
be
for the individual students not the
government-run institutions
and as i said you can still pick the
traditional public school if that's best
for you
and you should ask yourself as to why
families would choose to exit the system
to go to a private school or pandemic
pod
if the public schools are in fact doing
a good job for them it's probably
because they they prefer to do
to do something else with that money but
yeah just to get to oklahoma it was only
five percent of the funding and
they gave preference to low-income
families i i'm getting
several questions uh for john that
relate to the same point let me guess
one of them picks up
on a couple of things you said john that
you trust parents and you want to
empower
them and so the question is then if you
trust parents and want to empower
them then why not offer them uh
the uh the savings accounts that
will enable them uh to make their
empowering
and trustworthy choice of where they
want to send their kids
so that's the question and um let me be
clear about what but what the resolution
is that i'm arguing the affirmative for
is that it's it you know it's greater
investment
right as to not further
accommodate and privilege that choice
i'm not saying that choice shouldn't
exist
educational savings accounts and i i
think uh dr d'angelo's
pointing me in this direction man you
can like that's a really good
opportunity when you have the money to
do it no doubt about it and pay for my
daughter's college if i had the money to
do that i'm not going to deny that
choice to anybody i trust parents to
make that
but i'm looking at american history to
show that
historically and i mentioned this in my
opening arguments black
families and communities latinx families
and communities
and other families of color in the
united states have been historically
disadvantaged so i am
putting a specific parameters around who
we're talking about
i think white affluent parents are going
to do just fine i think they're going to
just i'm not worried about them i'm
worried about the nearly 51 million
families
who admittedly don't have a choice in in
many cases
but they have to go to the local public
school because they have to work two to
three jobs
right um so what i'm saying is yes i'm
not taking away that choice i think they
can empower that i think
greater investment is needed to allow
black and latinx families if they don't
even have a bank
in their neighborhood that doesn't
charge them extra and research shows
that this is true as well
that we need to invest in this through
something like financial literacy
classes
we offer this in the freedom schools all
across the
all across the country to families are
interested in that because
when you listen to families in public
schools they will say i want to take
better advantage of
x y and z and it requires a degree of
financial literacy that is oftentimes
not taught in public schools
and why because they have been under
funded for decades you can't put that in
the graph the fight
you go to any school and i'll look in
zoom camera at anybody going to a school
i will not go into a school and say you
have enough money
if you looked at baltimore schools and
detroit schools and speaking of detroit
the gary b
the gary b case right where they're
arguing that the basic fundamental right
of literacy is not being offered in
detroit
why dilapidated schools textbooks i'm
not going to go to detroit and say
you have enough money we're going to end
what little since we're going to send it
somewhere else
so again it's empowering local
communities to tell us
what investments they would like to see
that is correcting
and addressing this dual pandemic well
um to put a fine point on the question
john as well
do you oppose uh the proposal from the
other side
to give uh eighty percent of the
approximately
15 000 in money uh to offer that
to all families poor families as well
and of course
poor families including black and
hispanic do you propose do you impose
that proposal to offer them the 80
savings accounts so that they can
allocate it to wherever they want to
send their kids
as long as people take funding away from
the public schools themselves yeah i
would love that additional bump for
students to open the savings account
right but as long as you're not taking
that away
from students yeah that sounds like it
what the point i'm trying to make
a greater investment so if you are given
an 80
funded savings account to each student
right as long as they have someone else
to go if they want to
right my point is greater investments it
sounds like a greater investment it
sounds like it's providing some
opportunity
but rest assured that there should be a
public school
for these students to go to and these
families to rely on as well
well but what if what if they use that
80 to send their kids
to to to another program outside the
public school
well whatever again right
it depends on the local setting as long
as that local school that they did go to
and those kids who weren't making that
decision or the kids like
looking at studies coming to new orleans
where um
in many situations in many situations
parents actually choose a school that's
closest to them so those parents who
continue to choose because
parity and equal opportunity does not
exist again this isn't up for
it doesn't exist people are going to
naturally go to the public school where
research says as long as they still have
a school to go to
and we are still investing in that
public school sounds great because
that's fit in what my
what might what my point is greater
investments is needed so if you want to
tack that on sure
carl do you want to address the question
corey yeah i don't think we should fund
two people
for the price for for having one
education
uh it looks like john hill only supports
school choice even though he argues it
has racist origins
if it doesn't uh defund the traditional
public school and i will say school
choices and defund public schools
public schools defund families school
choices returns that
same money to the hands of the rightful
owners which is the family
and not the institution um so similarly
allowing families to stop at trader
joe's doesn't steal money from walmart
why because the money doesn't belong to
any particular
institution it's meant for that family
same thing with the education dollars
it's supposed to be meant for
for the education of a particular child
it's not supposed to be meant for
propping up and protecting
a government monopoly all right question
for uh you corey uh
what about students with disabilities
and special learning needs how would
they
pot up and receive the support they need
if putting
is left to market devices
yeah there's a lot of families with
students with special needs
using the arizona education savings
account which is targeted to students
with special needs there's actually
about 20 or 21
private school choice programs in the us
that are made and designed
specifically with special needs students
in mind and with my proposal
students with special needs since they
get more money in the traditional public
school system already
they would get much more money through
the education savings account program as
well which would
allow them to access a whole host of
other options could be the private
school it could be a charter school it
could be
a pandemic pod option or it could just
be a regular homeschool option that
would allow the families to offset the
cost
of homeschooling so that could allow for
more equity by allowing
less advantaged populations of students
to have more money
than more advantaged populations of
students and we're already seeing that
happen with prenda micro schools
in arizona uh today and i've already had
a parent
with us with a special needs child on my
podcast talking about her experience
with that and and and she saw it as a
positive experience
um so i think giving families an
additional option
for students with special needs is a
great idea too and i think um
this really uh is a movement in the
right direction especially when
uh the public school system is a
one-size-fits-all student that may not
work for every individual
child and if you have unique needs what
better way than to allow those students
to sort
into environments that work best for
them and that still could be the public
school
but i think too often the uh you know
the federal education laws and the ieps
don't actually meet the individual needs
of families in the current system
sometimes they do
but in some cases the the special needs
students
may just be put into a room all by their
themselves and not
able to interact with other students and
that might not be the
uh scenario that works best for them so
i think giving every student a choice is
a movement in the right direction
do you want to comment on that question
john i think you know
giving every student a choice is is a
bit misleading because it still
ignores the very problems where we have
in our traditional public schools i'm
not one i'm advocating for public
schools but i'm also admitting their
problems
but let's say you provide a choice
tomorrow to go wherever you want
research indicates that a lot of
families can go to the local school
because they have no other option they
don't have transfer
transportation go to other schools that
choice itself is not going to work if we
don't invest
people to make what corey's talking
about the right choice
or to use educational savings accounts
the most effectively
because as is the part of this argument
greater investments is need is just to
even
catch people up and raise all boats to
make that choice effectively
again i'm not denying choice to people
i'm not denied educational savings
accounts make that choice but
those who can't make the choice that go
to the best charter schools or go to the
best
you know find the best pandemic pods in
it within the city or whatever
we have to empower families
at times financially but there's other
forms of investment
and i know that this is a hard time
looking at this non-economic terms but
sometimes it's just showing up
and participating in debates like this
right that we
need to empower these communities to
even
get to the plane to make the choice that
we're talking about
and i continually go back to this that's
that's the argument investment in people
so they can be allowed and permitted and
empowered
to make these choices uh quick question
for you corey
i will we're running a bit out of time
so make it a little bit fast both guys
uh aren't there fixed costs to
the uh the structure of a public
institution
and if parents opt to abandon
the public school with those uh savings
accounts
then what about those fixed costs that
the uh government made in the
in the building yeah all costs are
variable in the long run just to start
out with basic economics lesson
but yes all businesses have fixed costs
but that doesn't mean they get to keep a
bunch of your money after you leave
uh walmart has fixed costs they have to
keep the lights on they have to keep
their buildings up and running but they
don't get to keep 20
of my grocery bill each week after i
leave they don't get to keep my a
portion of my food stamps after i leave
but the public schools actually do get
to keep a significant portion of dollars
even after families leave because
although public schools are funded based
on enrollment accounts they're not
entirely funded based on enrollment
accounts you can look this up at
georgetown universities at genomics lab
and they do this for each state and each
state has it's it's on average about 60
to 80 percent of the funding is based on
student enrollment counts what that
means mathematically is when you lose a
student to school choice competition
you get to keep 20 to 40 percent of the
funding for a student who is no longer
there
so the public schools actually
financially benefit on a per pupil basis
because they lose the student they lose
the cost of educating the student but
they get to keep 20 to 40
of the funding each year for a student
who's no longer there because they're
only partially funded based on
enrollment counts
just imagine if walmart got to keep 20
to 40 of your funding after you left
they would be happy about that and i
would argue the public schools
should be super happy that they get to
keep any money at all
um i'm afraid we're out of q a time uh
john i think you're hopefully okay that
you'll you'll have seven
and a half minutes of summation to both
answer that question and to summarize
your argument
so uh uh we're going to the summary
portion
of the debate take it away john your
summary
okay so again just to real quick to just
address what um corey is saying at the
end here again it's like
the schools i want to send my daughters
to are not walmart's i'm not comfortable
with that
i'm not you know that is not an analogy
that actually captures what's happening
on public schools that i work with
um in the community wherever i live it
doesn't capture that reality schools
provide
mental health resources they provide uh
medicine at a time where we're sending
kids in the direct right direction for
the health care
that they need because it's not being
provided in other areas so
it's much more than just going to
walmart to pick up you know
campbell's soup or something like that
it's not that it's providing these
social services so that requires
seeing outside the box a little bit in
terms of per student expenditures
right and that it's not
just simply money following the child
because
if that's the case that's much too
simple and it does not capture the
reality of public schools on the grounds
but what i want to really close by
saying is bringing us
back to the resolution and the
resolution is actually
quite simple for me that this dual
pandemic
has exposed the ugly
truth of racism it exposes a deadly
pandemic that has killed nearly 200
000 people after an administration even
really practically denied that it was an
issue
right so it's requiring greater
investment in communities that have been
ravaged by that to deny them greater
investment and again this grand
investment doesn't just have to be
financial we kept talking about you know
personal expenditures
thirteen thousand dollars per student
and that's one aspect of investment when
you go to schools if you go to a freedom
school you go to head start
invest it means showing up providing
your own food
take you know taking children on a field
trip it provides
finding their resources for crooked
that's investment it's showing
up and making it happen making you know
making ends meet for children
in schools we need greater investment
as this dual pandemic ravages america
it is it borders it begins to border on
an extreme position
to say that we shouldn't invest in our
schools
with that we shouldn't invest in
programs that we know
that black families need so the
resolution is quite simple
that we investment is needed however you
want to define it
in this specific historic moment in time
of a dual pandemic
that we cannot turn our backs on these
families
and say okay here's a little bit more
choice there's an educational savings
account
it's showing up doing the work and
pushing a public resort option that's
the investment that is needed
and i think you know
if we don't do that it privileges people
who can have the social capital and the
financial advantages to
take the best advantage of choice and
that
more than you know telling you to vote
for my proposal or
you know then that it's just at the end
of the day we really
need to pay attention not only pay
attention to these families who have
been ravaged by this dual pandemic
we need to show up and listen and
use their local expertise to foreign
policy
they will tell us what the investment
needs those closest to the problem of
family public schools are those i trust
the most
so i ask you tonight right to just
consider
what it would mean to take the time and
listen
and to really go to the most ravaged
communities and schools
listen to their solutions and and say
that we need
investment i'm here for the public
schools
i am here to advocate to make sure that
people who
will never have a choice can go to a
safe
decent place i'm not here to take away
your choice i'm not here to tell you
what to do
i'm here to advocate for public schools
and empower those communities
that i personally know depend on those
schools
thank you very much and corey i think i
just gave you a couple extra minutes
uh there's no no capitalist training of
minutes uh at
this debate uh john but thank you for
your intentions
and generosity uh corey uh you go
uh you have seven and a half minutes to
summarize your argument
take it away corey cool john hale just
finished by summing up his arguments
pretty well and he said that he is for
here for the public schools well i'm
here for the public school and private
school and every type of student
and we should give preference to the
individual students and individual
families in the system
and we should not uh prefer to help
and defend a government monopoly such as
the public school system
and so my counter proposal again for
everybody is to
fund the students directly and allow
them to take their children's education
dollars to
wherever they're getting an education
and this is an anti-public school
because you can
still take those dollars to the
traditional public school that option is
still on the table
but if for whatever reason you should be
able to take that money elsewhere to a
private school of your choosing
or to a pandemic pod as well and look
advantage families are already taking
advantage of these other opportunities
school choice allows less advantaged
families and if we fund students
directly it allows less advantaged
families
to be able to exercise these options as
well so school choice shouldn't be
limited to the rich and the powerful it
should be available
to everybody in society and education
savings accounts allowing the money to
follow the child
instead of the institution allows for
more families to be able to have that
equality of opportunity to be able to
empower to choose the schools that work
best for their children or the
homeschool setting that works best for
their child whether that be a regular
homeschool or a pandemic pod
and they should be able to have that
choice hail's proposal does nothing to
change the
poor incentives in the traditional
public school system yeah we could
fight harder to try to invest in the
system by having people talk about how
things should be better
we could throw more money at the problem
but that does nothing to change the
incentives of the individual schools
to cater to the needs of individual
families hail likes to point out that
walmart is not a school i understand
that but i'm just talking about
the food stamps as a funding mechanism
giving funding to families and letting
families choose
public walmart whole foods or any other
provider that's why i also
use the analogy of pre-k programs which
are also
uh schooling options and pell grant
programs and i'm just talking about the
funding mechanism in those cases the
funding goes to the student or the
family
and the student rightly has the choice
to spend that money at a public or
private university or public provider or
private provider of pre-k
uh in their locations and they should
have that choice but they should also
have that choice
when it comes to the years in between in
the k-12
education system a lot of um
john hill's arguments were about uh the
supposed racist origins of school choice
uh i've kind of gone over how school
choices existed well before the 1900s
three states have had private school
voucher programs and some
segregationists actually oppose full
choice because they knew that it would
lead to more racially integrated schools
and then eight to nine studies on this
topic find that private school choice
tends to lead to racial integration
because it allows students to
leave already segregated schools hail
admits that there are inequities in the
traditional public school system
and that's a good argument to allow
people to leave that inherently
unequal system that does not have a
strong incentive to cater to the needs
of individual families
again my proposal is not a
one-size-fits-all position whereas
hale's proposal to stay with the
traditional public school system
is a one-size-fits-all position we
should allow individual families to
choose
learning environments based on their
individual needs which a
one-size-fits-all
uh system will not uh
address and then also my proposal is
more timely
you can try to convince families to fix
things but we've already been waiting
for
four groups in the united states to try
to fix the public school system
we've increased per people spending by
280 in real time since 1960 and we've
almost doubled for people spending in
real terms
since 1980 and we've increased for
people spending by 40 percent already in
the traditional public school
system by uh 40 in real terms since 1990
so we've
we've done all of this before and we
haven't changed the incentives to do a
good job in the current system
what i'm arguing for allows for more
bottom-up accountability
at the same time as allowing for more
freedom for disadvantaged groups to be
able to
escape that system and they don't have
to escape the system though they can
also choose the traditional public
schools
but for whatever reason that's not
working for their family
they should be able to pick something
else it shouldn't these choices
shouldn't be limited
to people who can afford to pay for
private school tuition and fees out of
pocket i will just point out
80 percent of the 15 000 in traditional
public schools that we spend today
is around 12 thousand which is well over
what we spend on private schools
uh for average private school tuition in
the us which is about eleven thousand
dollars according to
private school reviews website in 2020.
so this would allow for a lot of
families to have a lot of different
choices
and this would be good for teachers too
we already have teachers opting out of
the traditional public school system
to teach at pandemic pods we saw a story
in washington post
by a of a teacher in new jersey who was
in the public school system for 20 years
and then they left to do a pandemic pod
they completely left the system
because they saw that there could be
smaller class sizes only six students
versus the 20 to 30 to 40 students that
could be in the traditional public
school system
and more autonomy they didn't have to
deal with all the regulations in the
public school system
and they could they could eventually end
up in making more money if the money
followed the child
because then more of the money could get
directly from the student to the teacher
and you wouldn't have to spend the money
on all the other
uh things in the middle some money can
more easily get from
students teachers and also we'll say we
you know we have spent more money in the
system
but not a lot of that money has actually
gone to teachers so when you go to you
know
particular school districts and see that
the teachers are having to buy supplies
and that they're not making a
a ton of money it's because the school
district doesn't have a strong incentive
because they have residentially assigned
monopolies
uh to spend the money wisely and if you
look at ben scaffoody's work on this
between 1992 and 2014 we've increased
real
people education expenditures by about
27 in the us
but real teacher salaries have actually
dropped by 2 over the same time period
and i would argue it's because the
monopoly system does not have a strong
incentive to spend its money wisely and
the most wise
way to spend the money in the system is
to allocate it towards the classroom
towards the students and towards the
teachers so this could be a benefit
for teachers it could be a benefit for
families it could be a
an equalizer because it can allow less
advantage families to have more options
and empowerment as well
just yeah just hoping the traditional
public school system is going to work
for everyone
assumes that one size fits all it
doesn't and it also
assumes that advantage families aren't
going to choose
to do something else um and and even if
they do choose to go back to the public
school system
advantage families will probably go back
into the school the more advantaged
schools because we have inequities in
that traditional public school system
so incentivizing families to return to
the schools they were already going to
which are already unequal does not lead
to more equality
funding families directly leads to more
equality by allowing
families who did not have the power to
make these choices to now have the same
uh more power to make individual
decisions about
uh the type of school that their
children will attend whether that's a
public school a private school
or a pandemic pod option and uh my
resolution is also
more timely and it could be more safe by
spreading more children out to different
locations
and um better learning environments and
so i just want to say thank you so much
john hale for this uh participating i
want to say thank you to everyone
and if you prefer my resolution to john
hills you will vote against john hales
thank you
thank you corey all right well that
concludes uh the
debate uh jane please
open the final vote again
the resolution reads to combat
inequality
greater investments must be made in
public schools stores not to accommodate
the formation
of pandemic pods by affluent parents
john uh
your book uh is uh your book is i guess
available on amazon although
not yet available you can order it on
the link is that correct john yes
john i have two books on the freedom
schools uh one
uh which you can find on amazon and the
book on the origins of school choice
will be available for beacon for
beacon principles we'll we'll post a
link to that as you request an amazon
link on our on our website
uh and while we're waiting i did have a
question
at least an objection to what i've been
doing
my my timer light goes off occasionally
and uh
and the person who talked about how
foolish this is
doesn't realize that actually i'm
actually renting a tiny office
in downtown manhattan and i have no
control over it
i don't like these things either so
please bear that in mind that it's not
my choice since we've been talking about
choice
this evening and then while uh the
closing vote is coming in
i do want to announce that we have a
debate scheduled
for october 18th sunday afternoon
october 18th
at 3 p.m new york city time that's our
next debate
in that case the debate resolution will
read
to combat climate change the world's
nations
must make it their highest priority to
completely replace
the burning of fossil fuels within the
next
20 years defending that resolution
will be jeff nesbitt executive director
of climate nexus
uh a non-profit that works on climate
change and clean energy solutions
jeff nesbitt is the author of this is
the way the world
ends how droughts and die-offs
heat waves and hurricanes are converging
on america
opposing the resolution will be bjorn
lumberg
author of false alarm how climate change
panic costs us trillions hurts the poor
and fails to fix the planet
we'll host that debate at 3 pm in order
to accommodate the fact
that bjorn lemberg will be in europe
where the time will be
several hours later again that will be
on sunday afternoon
october 18th and tickets
are already available for that debate on
our website
john and cory on you have comm ticks if
you would like to do that
debate as part of our audience just as a
reward
for your uh polite and energetic efforts
in terms of this debate i'm seeing jane
menton on screen
jane do you have the final voting
just sending me thank you jane uh and uh
i don't see it yet let me see you
emailed it to me jane
oh there we go okay um
all right um okay uh
uh the uh the yes vote for the
resolution
uh uh having to do with greater
investment in education
uh began at 15 and
it went up to 20 congratulations
john for gaining five percentage points
on that uh the pre and post uh and but
uh that five percentage points is the
number to beat
uh the uh resolution on no the no vote
began with 45 and it went up to
75 picking up 30 percentage points
so corey d'angelos wins the tootsie roll
congratulations corey and thanks and
congratulations
to you both for spirited and courteous
debate
we hope to see you soon on october 18th
and
we hope all of you people can eventually
come
to the subculture theater at 45 glico
street for a physical debate
john hale corey you're invited as well
we're going to that one
that'll be more fun thank you and good
night john and corey
my pleasure take care thanks
[Music]
you